good luck don't die
yay remember einen darkest okay thank
you
let's see here I think no it's gotta be
this one
yeah I'm back sorry for late upload I
was busy doing the weekend
and it's more difficult for me to record
when I'm not singing at home alone
anymore like when there's other people
around I want to be home alone when I
play this and I'm at this [ __ ] place
and when I have no idea what to do yes
can't wait to solve this puzzle this
lever you just pulled down for hungry
though well I have all these stuff yeah
find it shut up barrels Jesus
let's check this place out I guess
hovering bottles why the [ __ ] not
oh yeah this is this place that one
isn't black hmm maybe that's a club I
don't know there's another one just make
sure I haven't missed anything
well I got a sneeze coming nope not
today
drive oil good boy
isn't this where we found Jesus yeah it
is
hey I never won in here all because you
can't open it Gracie
I never run in here
this is bad thing water
nothing to see here this moment there's
the Jesus penis flying use assignment
and this is where I look yeah I've come
this but it's weird because it's like oh
here we go
oh here we go some oil just a few drops
with whatever nothing in there lever the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] did I do
don't you dare make a trick on me hey
move
oh that help listen here then yeah stuff
yes you've gotta be kidding me
Wow did something let's just find that
another one again because I don't really
remember
already lost I think it was in here yes
all right what is it various don't you
dare go up again nope
ow ah by the power of Grayskull
Meyer yes
I want
now what - is slow
don't tell me it's another bookshelf
thing oh man
hey this is third one I don't know that
it's there's no lever
yes so we know where we came from I
heard it is
but
I doubt this'll work but you never know
whoa holy [ __ ] work six lotion I'm on
fire today came to power it's on fire
here we go whoa the wall scared me Hey
oh crap ease down there
ah shut up where's I should just run
play
screw you I'm going home
it's going here I guess ah
nothing in here
whoop-whoop I wonder if I know don't
roll on me barrel ah okay don't jump on
there
oh man I hate him so much what have I
done to you
oh crap uh-oh ouch ouch bro else roars
roar aah when I run back Oh sanity
doesn't help right now come on wait what
am i standing on [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
hey disappear holy [ __ ] I beat the game
all right [ __ ] I forgot holy cow
oh I'm out of oil come on
oh [ __ ] you spike
crap what I'm so screwed
ah [ __ ]
sneaky little bastard oh man I have to
carry on apparently Oh from here now the
rum text will appear run rear Oh wrong
direction right
god I hate him some [ __ ] lunch
I can't get up on that one ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh crap ah he's right behind me isn't he
how the [ __ ] am i ah crap crap crap
oh wait did I do that oh man oh man oh
man oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man
oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man oh
man oh man oh man oh but ah ah I don't
want to carry on this place is horrible
I have no idea what to do you need to
find a key
crap
there's nothing in there I remember that
up
ah
oh why do I run backwards ah ah ah okay
coming here Kenny hi lucky cap ah oh my
god
I'm so slow is ridiculous
yar um Danielle
I prefer flying Jesus I really do I just
don't know where to go
I really really really don't know where
to go oh [ __ ] are you kidding me
and you find a [ __ ] key
um-hum
I hate this door
oh man
come on
ah down boy ah I'm screwed
actually I'm not good how the funny okay
that's good
ah maybe this should go up now they
don't go up uh
yeah I'm taking a [ __ ] break